Je vous en parle plus longuement à la fin de la vidéo.
Elle est folle cette question, non?
Moi je la trouve ouf.
Elle me retourne le cerveau quoi.
Parce qu’a priori, on ne mesure pas "maintenant" ; on le ressent.
Dans une vidéo d’il y a 4 ans, je vous faisais cette citation :
D'ailleurs, je trouve ça intéressant de creuser le sujet des sens.
Parce qu’on nous parle beaucoup de l'ouïe, de l'odorat, la vue, le goût, le toucher...
Il y en a d’autres aussi :
- L’écholocalisation, qui nous permet d'appréhender notre environnement en fonction des ondes sonores
qui se répercutent sur les murs et les objets ;
Le proprioception : C’est-à-dire l a perception de son propre corps,
Donc c’est ce qui va nous permettre par exemple,
de manger, c’est-à-dire de mettre quelque chose dans notre bouche,
sans pouvoir voir notre bouche ;
- L'équilibrioception : C'est-à-dire le sens de l'équilibre tout simplement ;
- Ou encore, la thermoception : c'est-à-dire la perception de la chaleur ou son absence.
Mais le temps?
Ressentir le temps?
La perception du temps.
On en parle?
Non.
Non, justement on n’en parle pas.
On n'en parle pas tellement c’est évident.
Quand je parle d'évidence, je parle d'évidence métaphysique.
C’est quelque chose d'immédiat, il n’y a pas d'analyse, de réflexion.
Ça nous est donné entièrement, immédiatement.
C’est pour ça que cette question est forte.
Parce qu’on ne se la pose jamais.
C’est comme s’il n'y avait pas de réponse.
Et pourtant, il y en a plein.
Et pour vous en parler correctement, j’ai envie de vous parler de :
Il est chercheur à l' :
à Freiburg, en Allemagne.
Il a écrit un livre qui s'appelle : Felt Time, The Psychology of How We Perceive Time
Marc Wittmann nous parle de 3 différents moments :
Je vais les traduire par :
Le moment fonctionnel, c'est la première granularité.
C’est le plus petit élément de notre conscience temporelle.
C’est grâce à ça si l’on devine que deux éléments arrivent simultanément, ou non.
Donc c’est très précis, ça va de 0 à 300 millisecondes.
Ça va très vite, mais parfois, ça ne va pas assez vite.
Il peut y avoir un très court laps de temps entre le moment où un évènement
a lieu et le moment ou l’on perçoit cet évènement.
Et d’ailleurs nos sens ne sont pas égaux pas rapport à ça.
Par exemple auditivement, on est assez chaud parce qu’il suffit
d’un écart de 2 à 3 millisecondes entre deux stimuli
pour qu’on les considère comme non-simultanés.
Alors qu’au niveau de la vision, on est plus autour des 10 millisecondes.
D’ailleurs c’est intéressant parce que ce n’est pas parce que ce n’est pas simultané
que notre cerveau  est capable de savoir lequel est arrivé en premier.
Je trouve ça fou.
Alors ce que je vous dis là est issu d’une seule et même étude.
Je vous mets quand même, comme ça vous savez que je ne vous dis pas n’importe quoi.
Vous êtes entrain de regarder un contenu de qualité,
Vous pouvez vous applaudir.
(Applaudissement)
Félicitations, non félicitations.
Ça, c’était ce que l’on va appeler le moment fonctionnel.
Il va donc de 3 millisecondes à 300 millisecondes.
OK.
Maintenant, on va parler du Experienced Moment.
Le moment ressenti.
Le moment ressenti va de 300 à 3000 millisecondes, soit 3 secondes.
C'est dans ces 3 secondes que notre impression de "maintenant" arrive.
D'où cette phrase de Poppel (qui a fait l’étude dont j’ai parlée  juste avant),
Qui dit la chose suivante :
Qu’on pourrait traduire par :
Ces 3 secondes c’est la durée la plus longue de "maintenant".
Et Poppel prend un exemple fort, celui du métronome.
Prenons un métronome de 120 bpm.
(Métronome à 120bpm)
C’est constant et c’est le même son et pourtant,
je peux faire des groupements différents.
(Métronome à 120bpm)
Je peux faire : (un deux) (un deux) (un deux)
Ou bien je peux faire :
(Métronome à 120bpm)
(un, deux, trois) (un, deux, trois) (un deux trois)
C’est une différence principale entre le moment fonctionnel et le moment ressenti.
Je peux recevoir les stimuli passivement,
ou bien je peux influer sur la manière dont je reçois les stimuli.
Et vous remarquerez que ça marche tant que l'intervalle entre les sons,
ne dépasse pas les quelques secondes, plus ça devient compliqué.
Par exemple sur du 60 bpm, ça devient compliqué.
(Métronome à 60bpm)
On peut difficilement les regrouper par 3.
Poppel est d’ailleurs allait plus loin puisqu’il a remarqué que dans le phrasé,
dans de nombreuses langues étudiées,
Quand c’est naturel — donc pas quand on lit un texte — on va parler
par groupes de 3 secondes.
Je crois que c'est exactement ce que je viens de faire.
(Bruit explosion)
(Bruit explosion x2)
(Gros bruit d'explosion)
Alors évidemment, quand on dit que c’est 3 secondes,
c'est de l'ordre de l'estimation
Mais, c’est de dire que ce n'est pas des millisecondes,
et que ce n’est pas des dizaines de secondes
On a donc vu le moment fonctionnel et le moment ressenti, mais si on s'attache à ces concepts-là,
On aurait l’impression juste de vivre une succession...
d'instants présents.
Or ce n’est pas ça.
On a une impression globale.
On ne ressent qu’un seul présent.
C’est pour ça qu'il faut qu’on parle, des Mental Present.
La présence mentale qui va de quelques secondes à quelques minutes.
La présence mentale fait appel à notre mémoire de travail.
C’est un modèle fonctionnel de la mémoire à court terme,
qui est proposé par Alan Baddeley.
C’est une digression, mais en gros la différence entre le deux
est que la mémoire à court terme est généralement exposée,
comme une mémoire pouvant nous permettre de maintenir
temporairement une information.
Alors que la mémoire de travail,
C'est exposé comme une mémoire qui va nous permettre
non seulement de maintenir temporairement une information,
mais aussi de la manipuler.
Donc la présence mentale fait appel à cette notion de mémoire du travail,
qui va nous permettre de traiter des informations et stimuli,
pour une période de temps qui excède quelques secondes,
et donc ça va nous donner cette sensation uniformisée de présent.
Donc ces limites sont beaucoup plus floues que le moment fonctionnel et ressenti,
puisqu'en fait ça va dépendre de ce qu’on a gardé dans cette mémoire de travail,
et ça s’effrite graduellement.
Les expériences de perception de niveau inférieur,
s'imbriquent donc dans le niveau supérieur :
la présence mentale.
Les moments ressentis, que je vis, sont imbriqués
dans la présence mentale
Quand on parle d’un instant présent qu’on a vécu, on fait écho
à ces moments ressentis de quelques secondes.
C’est la présence mentale, dans laquelle tout ça s'imbrique
qui fait qu’on a la conscience de son soi présent,
avec sa narration et ses commentaires.
Wittmann dit :
Et il a une image, très belle je trouve, du moment présent,
puisqu’il parle de la vague de l'Eisbach,
une rivière artificielle, à Munich.
Elle suit constamment le flot de l'eau et en même temps
elle varie extrêmement peu, comme cette sensation très stable du moment présent
Roooh qu'est-ce que c’est beau, non, mais sans dé******
je trouve ça magnifique, non, mais on est dans de la poésie aujourd’hui je vous jure. Voilà.
(reniflement)
On est là, mais, je sens l’eau de rose ou quoi ?
Je n’en ai pas fini avec vous, il y a une autre manière d’aborder la question.
Et elle est cosmique cette fois.
Du point de vue d’un photon, ce "maintenant",
le "maintenant du Big Bang, tous les "maintenant" entre les deux
et les "maintenant" à venir, arrivent tous simultanément.
Donc d’un point de vue cosmique, "maintenant" n’a pas de sens.
(grosse explosion)
Où est-ce que ça s'arrête
Quand est-ce que ça s'arrête?
Ça va trop loin. Ça va trop loin.
J'adore.
Les trucs mind-blowing comme ça, j'adore
J’ai l’impression de prendre claque sur claque.
J’ai pris un plaisir à écrire cette vidéo, vous n'imaginez pas.
Alors maintenant qu’on peut estimer combien de temps dure "maintenant",
et surtout qu'est-ce que c’est "maintenant".
On peut se poser une autre question essentielle.
Comment vivre dans "maintenant"?
Dans l’instant présent?
Et surtout, à quoi ça sert?
Stoïcisme, Bouddhisme… Il y a beaucoup de philosophies de bonheur qui le prônent,
j’en ai déjà parlé sur cette chaîne, et je pense que je vais en reparler.
Mais je voulais vous parler d’un outil clef pour ça : c’est la méditation.
C’est d’ailleurs pour ça que j’ai fait des lives méditation guidée pendant tout le premier confinement.
Et aujourd’hui je suis très content et très fier d’avoir comme sponsor de cette vidéo :
Petit BamBou.
Instant promo ! Petit BamBou c’est vraiment une app' que je recommande à chaque fois,
parce que j’ai vraiment vu des gens l'utiliser autour de moi,
et voir à quel point ça les a aidé dans leurs vies de tous les jours.
Moi je vais être honnête avec vous, je fais très peu de méditation guidée,
parce que j’en ai fait beaucoup à un moment et de manière intensive,
donc maintenant je mets juste un timer.
Mais à chaque fois que vous m’écrivez pour me demander conseil
sur une app’ de méditation guidée, je vous conseille toujours :
au minimum, Petit BamBou.
Très franchement, et c’est pour ça que je suis très content de faire ce partenariat avec eux.
Aujourd’hui je médite tous les jours, la méditation fait partie de ma vie et,
je vous encourage à faire de même.
On me demande à quoi ça sert,
ça sert à s’écouter davantage, moins se juger, être présent à soi-même et
aborder les évènements extérieurs avec plus de sérénité.
Alors ce n’est pas un miracle hein.
C’est une activité qu’on fait, qu’on pratique,
et comme toutes les activités parfois c’est très cool,
parfois c’est chiant.
Voilà, et la méditation d’ailleurs nous aide à accepter ça.
Vous n’allez pas oublier tous vos problèmes en méditant.
Ça c’est faux.
Mais ça va vous aider à être plus à l’aise avec.
Il y a un programme de découverte avec 8 séances disponibles pour toutes et tous.
Ils ont aussi une fonctionnalité qui s’appelle méditation du jour,
avec une méditation qui change par jour avec des voix différentes, et cetera.
Vous pouvez mettre la durée que vous voulez entre 8 minutes, 12 minutes, 16 minutes,
suivant le temps que vous avez.
Je vous mets le lien en description, checkez au moins le programme de découverte,
je suis sûr que ça vous parlera.
Et que vraiment ça peut vous apporter quelque chose.
J’espère que ça vous plaira, j'attends vos retours.
En tout cas j’espère que cette vidéo vous a plu, ça fait très longtemps
que j’avais envie de faire cette vidéo.
Elle était dans mes sujets de trucs dont je voulais parler
Pourquoi, parce que cette question m’a vraiment retourné la tête.
J’espère que ça vous a plu.
Quand je l'ai eu je l'ai trouvée folle, du coup je me suis dit fallait une réponse.
Et n’oubliez pas tous les mardis 22h sur Twitch.
Love. Peace.
(Bruit baiser)
Tchao!